the netflix fantasy series curse makes a
lot of changes to the classic arthurian
legend
and raises a lot of new mysteries here
are some of the biggest questions which
are still left unanswered by the end of
the show's first season
from the very beginning curse lets us
know that nimwei is eventually doomed to
sink into a deep body of water
while bleeding from multiple arrow
wounds during the closing minutes of the
first season
we finally see how that happens while
attempting to save a wounded merlin
alongside morgana
nimwei is confronted by a bow and
arrow-wielding sister iris
iris ignores limway's pleas for mercy
and fires several arrows into her
despite merlin's attempt to save her
nimway tumbles from the bridge
disappearing into the churning waters
below and leaving the sword of power
abandoned on the bridge
when last we see her nimwei is sinking
to her supposed death
recalling the image that opened the
season however despite all signs
pointing to nimway dying
her role in the arthurian legend as the
mystical lady of the lake
indicates that she'll survive somehow
nimway showed herself capable of
tremendous magic throughout the course
of the season
maybe merlin will use his magic to save
her or perhaps nimwei will save herself
through her own magic
when nimwei realizes that merlin is her
biological father
she finally understands why her mother
tasked her with bringing the sword of
power to him
even more pieces fall into place when
merlin shows her the circumstances that
led to her own conception
the two met when nimway's mother lenore
healed merlin from something inside his
chest that was causing him pain
she promptly cut him open to extract it
and was shocked to pull out the very
sword of power
that nimwei returns to him years later
merlin mentions that the sword was his
once but never explains how it ended up
inside him
the most he offers is that it wasn't an
enemy who did it but beyond that
we never get any information on what the
sword was doing inside merlin's body was
he hiding it was it a curse
we may never know or at least not by the
end of season one
merlin insinuates several times and he's
actually hundreds of years old
but we never uncover the reason behind
his staggeringly long life
originally merlin was born into the
faith but his powers seem to exceed
those of the other fae that we meet
when we encounter merlin and curse he's
been without his magic for some time
and we later learn that he's lost his
powers when lenore extracted the sword
of power from his body
merlin spends most of the season
endeavoring to get his magic back
through various methods
and as he does he winds up brushing
against death quite a few times
at one point after having been stabbed
multiple times through the chest
he even asked a rhetorical question why
can't i die
it's a good question not only should his
stab wounds have been mortal but he was
shot in the heart with an arrow earlier
in the same episode
we see plenty of other fade die over the
course of cursed so what makes merlin
different
probably one of the biggest twists curse
throws at his audience comes when we
learn the true identity of the weeping
monk that has been terrorizing the fae
for the entire season
a long time ago my name was lancelot the
weeping monk's adopted father is father
karden
leader of the red paladins who despised
the fae and their magic
but midway through the series gawain the
green knight recognizes the weeping monk
as a fellow faye
by the end of the season the weeping
monk has turned on his adoptive father
saving the young feyboy squirrel yet the
reveal that the monk was actually named
lancelot before he was taken by father
cardian
still comes as quite a shock cardin
tells lancelot that he spared him from
the slaughter of his village
because of his ability to sense other
fae but considering karden's track
record
we can't believe that that's a complete
story we're curious to learn more about
the young lancelot before kardin took
him
while curse is upfront about the
identities of legendary characters such
as merlin and arthur
it enjoys doling out the more famous
names of other characters throughout the
course of the season
on several occasions characters we've
met under one name reveal that their
actual name is much more familiar
it grains my grandmother's name it's a
bit of a mix up when they first brought
me here
to friends i'm morgana go squirrel
i won't leave you here it begs a
question of whether there are any other
well-known arthurian characters who have
already made an appearance but under
different names
since curse plays pretty fast and loose
for the characters backstories we can't
rule anyone out
after all if the chivalrous knight
lancelot can be introduced as one of the
season's most terrifying villains
anything is possible perhaps sister iris
or pym will eventually turn out to be
familiar characters
from the legend or a minor character
will turn out to be more mythologically
important than we thought
something about virus has always seemed
a little strange starting with her first
meeting with nimway where iris reveals
how she can spot demons
i just stare at them i stare at them
until i see through their faces to their
real faces
it's clear that iris and nimway are
likely not going to be friends
and sure enough iris is soon burning
down the abbey and attempting to find
the red paladins determined to join
their bloody cause by killing nimway
but while iris is certainly motivated by
a strong hatred of the fae and their
magic
there seems to be more to her than that
several times she seems to be internally
conflicted
about the path she's set for herself and
at one point she punishes herself for
straying from her task
by burning her own arm over an open
flame berating herself
as though she's of two minds between her
radical hatred her unflinching capacity
for violence
and her strange internal debates we
wonder if there's a lot more to sister
iris than meets eye
when nimway asks merlin about the sword
of power he admits that it was once his
and that at one time he might have
desired it again however he claims his
motives have since changed
let me destroy it what
that's my true intention if you must
know it it turns out merlin did want the
sword back almost immediately after
lenoir extracted it from his chest
since he realized the sword was tied to
his magic at the time lenore lied and
told him that she had destroyed the
sword but by the time he learns that
nimwei is his daughter
he seems to have experienced a true
change of heart and seems sincere about
destroying the sword
yet by the end of the season merlin's
magic has returned and it seems to be
tied directly to his reclaiming of the
sword the last we see of him he survives
only by channeling the sword's magic
will he still be committed to destroying
the sword now that he's had a taste of
its power again
we'll have to find out nimwei may be the
character who spends the most time with
the sword of power but merlin has the
longest history with the magical object
the first indication of merlin's
connection to the sword came when he was
struck by lightning
and branded with a sword-shaped burn
mark that ran the length of his body
later we learned that the sword was at
one time merlin's that has somehow wound
up embedded inside his body
and that his magic has somehow linked to
it yet for every small detail we do know
there's plenty we don't
where did the sword come from before it
came into merlin's possession and how
did it get so strongly linked to him
what is the source and extent of its
magical abilities for an object that was
at the center of most of the conflicts
in cursed first season
we actually know very little about it
and are eager to learn more
midway through kurt's first season king
uther pendragon receives a rude
awakening when he learns that he is not
in fact
royal by birth and it always assumed it
turns out that when his mother was
pregnant with her son
complications in childbirth led to the
baby being delivered still born
the king had just died several months
prior and desperate for an heir the
queen sent her midwife out to pay a
local peasant to give up her baby
the midwife returned the baby to the
queen who raised him as her own
utha learns that his biological mother
was named sylvia
and that she died shortly after giving
up her child at the age of only 19.
enraged uther poisons the queen with
spiced wine which is the same method she
used to kill sylvia however as far as we
know
sylvia was the only member of his family
ever killed as part of the queen's
cover-up which means his father may
still be out there somewhere along with
other members of his family will he go
seeking them or will he eventually track
him down
we'll have to wait and see once the
truth of uther's illegitimacy begins to
come to light
the viking ruler come by the ice king
arrives with a claim to the throne
although cumber claims to have pain
dragon lineage it is never clarified
exactly what his relationship to the
late king was the most we learn is when
the midwife gives cumber a blood-soaked
cloth
presumably from the queen's stillbirth
this is the blood of my cousin
it is my lord perhaps his use of the
word cousin means that cumber was the
king's nephew however
cousin could also be a broader term
referring to any distant relative
in which case cumber's bloodline could
have diverged with the pen dragons
several generations earlier it will be
interesting to see whether the
connection between cumber and the pen
dragons
is explored further in future seasons
and exactly what that connection is
many times throughout curse uther seems
to refer to himself in the plural
using pronouns like we and our to
express his thoughts and opinions
tear us down and you will suffer
as we suffer there doesn't appear to be
much rhyme or reason to when he uses
plural pronouns and when he refers to
himself
as i begging the question of what
exactly is going on here
maybe uther is referring to either his
kingdom or his court when he speaks in
the plural
but that doesn't feel like what is
happening at times it almost seems like
there may be multiple consciousnesses
warring inside him
yet no one ever seems to blink at his
fluid oscillation between singular and
plural pronouns
suggesting that either no one notices or
everyone has just accepted it as a
strange quirk
we have to wonder who uther is referring
to whenever he says we
and if we'll ever learn any more about
them the mysterious shrouded character
known only as the widow
appears in a handful of episodes to warn
characters that death may be swiftly
approaching
while it's obvious that the widow has
one foot in the world of the living and
the other in the world of the dead
very little has ever communicated about
her identity some sort of shared history
with merlin is hinted at but no real
detail is ever given
adding another intriguing layer to the
mystery of the widow is that she's not
actually immortal
morgana actually manages to kill her
off-screen toward the end of season 1
and subsequently takes her place even
more ghana herself isn't entirely sure
how it happens
but her becoming the new widow suggests
that the previous widow was also one
someone else entirely
was she someone merlin new how did she
become the widow
and who was the widow before her we'll
just have to hold out hope that curse
gets a second season so we can find out
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one